hallo liebe leute herzlich willkommen
zurück bei einer neuen episode von the
german wir sind heute wieder in münster
afp
nein nicht zu sehen hier essen zu fall
ich bin gerade auf dem weg zu klaus wir
wollten bisschen grillen heute den
sommer begrüßen
klaus klaus in seinem haus oder was bist
du mich eingeladen
weißt du was ich mir nicht mit als
überraschungsgast meinst du das ja das
machen wir ja cool dann gehen wir jetzt
mal grill micron und auf geht's carré
also war klaus im haus nicht immer
richtig gerne das trifft sich gut denn
hier sind wir auch schon sitzt ja auch
hier
sie ist auch hier alle sind was gibt's
denn heute hier ja wir wollten grillen
heute hallo mit so ja sehr gerne kommen
mit den garten ihren zuschauer wollen ja
auch schon immer mal wissen wie man so
ingrid in deutschland noch weil das weiß
auch keiner
er suchte schon jetzt gehen wir und
klaus und malin zeigen wir uns erst mal
den grill anwerfen
ja da unten kommen das eigenkapital das
kann man dann hier an der seite gleich
anziehen da kannst du bist ein bisschen
rausnehmen so kommt die kohle drei oben
kommt die kohle fun fact für euch im
deutschen gibt es kohle ist sowohl die
kohle zum grill und feuer machen
kohle ist aber auch einen slot für geld
also wenn ich sage klasse kohle und er
sagt natürlich nicht er weiß man gar
nicht was gemeint ist
jetzt hast du auch daran den language
tipp weggenommen dann mach ich schon mal
unten an meinte das klappt zu das sollte
so klappen
genau vielleicht können wir noch an
einer anderen stelle wie ihr sehen könnt
dampf das jetzt hier schon ganz
ordentlich
genau das feuer entwickelt sich da unten
ja man ihn was machst du jetzt hier ja
klaus hat hier ist unser land
vorbereitet mit getroffenen getrockneten
eingelegten tomaten rotem testo oliven
feta käse und grundlage sind so ist es
nicht glauben aber wir haben auch eine
grillzange
das braucht man ja um auf dem grill das
grillgut zu wenden da martina gerade der
sommer sei jetzt nicht mehr aufzuhalten
was sagst du dazu festgehalten
ich glaube es ist alles schwein und das
islam für die von janosch wieso das
nennen das symbol zu hart ist und weil
janosch der beste kameramann aller
zeiten ist
wir haben es keinen freund irgendwas
fehlt auch hier heute oder ja peter
peter wetter war auch eingeladen aber er
hat es vorgezogen nicht hierhin zu
kommen
angeblich hat er heute eine uni
veranstaltung ich dachte wir rufen jetzt
einfach mal an um zu testen ob er
überhaupt wirklich wie sie ist
wir haben aber nach den signalen die
möglichkeit ihren namen und eine
nachricht
carina schmidt klaus brenke
peter wo bist du bist du wirklich in der
uni wir gaben die nicht freitagabends
hat niemand uni peter wenn du das siehst
wir vermissen dich
martin hat aber eben schon das ein oder
andere tränchen verdrückt das lag aber
nicht die schoten und den gebratenen
zwiebeln bisschen mit dem salat fertig
lese grill an das beste ist das bier
steht draußen ihren kühlschrank der
grips an die kunden nicht ehrliche
hinsetzen durchatmen weiter abgeflaut
zug aus wie geht's weiter so wir müssen
jetzt die pilze füllen und zwar das ist
eigentlich sehr einfach man nimmt
einfach den löffel und dann macht man
das ja so schön rein maji maji zufällig
als sie das hier dein gehirn martin
hatte klaus und vorgekocht was hat klaus
und vergessen als er genug auskühlen hat
lassen
ja ich hab es auf es gibt leute die
machen
ursula weiß bescheid möchten sie diese
frage wann er hat sie nicht mit kaltem
wasser abgeschreckt er hat die nudeln
nicht abgeschreckt da haben wir den
salat klaus model nicht abgeschreckt und
er hat auch keine butter dazu gegeben
nein erstens er sagt keine butter
zweitens das ja nicht abschrecken das
abschrecken habe ich nicht gemacht weil
in dem augenblick wo die fertig war kam
martin an und da musste ich mir erst mal
getränke anbieten weil er sehr aus
dürstet war defekt für zwischendurch
main ist in deutschland noch ein
sprichwort das heißt das ist schon offen
und zwar da haben wir den salat
ja da haben wir den salat ja wird
meistens im zusammenhang verwendet oder
in situationen verwendet wo irgendwas
schief gegangen ist ja so und das kann
man natürlich auf die situation ganz gut
anwenden denn
das mit den nudeln hat ja nicht so gut
geklappt da haben wir also den salat
jetzt wir in der live zeuge davon wie
martin dass die kohle auf den grill
kippt der griff ist ganz schön heiß man
muss aufpassen dass man hier nicht neben
das holz greift noch nie gesehen und
jetzt stehen wir einfach brauchst du
eine brücke stock klaus das wort kennen
keine angst ich einen stockum in der
kolonie zu bröckeln
ach so dass auch nicht für sinnvoll dass
henri guisan benutzen sie wie soll man
die kirche ja also aber doch einen
stocker stock würde ich ja eigentlich
draußen
es gibt ja übrigens auch so ein
deutsches sprichwort einen stock im
arsch haben das hat man tatsächlich
jemand auf der straße gesagt nämlich ein
amerikaner hat es über die deutschen
gesagt danke nochmal das heißt es ja ein
bisschen stock mal da ist ja so steif zu
sein sich nicht gehen lassen zu können
vielleicht ist das besser klar als also
das spricht man in the march zu erklären
stock im arsch bedeutet dass man nicht
entspannt ist nicht nicht relaxt ist
sondern dass man er immer sehr
angespannt ist
woher kommt das kannst du es endlich
erklären ich möchte dass das überlasse
ich jedem zuschauer selbst sich das
vorzustellen
die temperatur mit der achte temperatur
steigt stetig wir sind jetzt gleich bei
150 grad
ich hätte das mal zu gemacht und hier
wie die lüftungsschlitze aufgemacht er
an beiden seiten kann man so damit die
luft zirkuliert und ja die temperatur
steigt weiter in der zwischenzeit haben
wir für die outtakes ein bisschen was
vorbereitet
wir haben lieder rat mit dem stock
gespielt und zwar man muss mit dem stock
in die luft schlagen und dabei den
rhythmus von einem lied quasi nachmachen
und klaus zeigt jetzt mal wie das geht
und macht bist du dran so witzig alle
anderen kinder kritisch kann du nicht
mal gucken was reizt
mit hits wie heißt das lied richtig
heißen dass meine sehr fetten damen und
herren carina schmidt in ihrer besten
rolle
bild fertig was ist das pilz halle
fertig erwartet ein das ist ein
gefüllter pilz jetzt in aluminiumfolie
auf den grill gelegt wird und er muss
jetzt ein halbes schon drauf liegen und
dann ist ja gut so klaus was passiert
jetzt hinlegen das grillgut drauf also
die würstchen habe ich schon drauf
gelegt gerade ganz geheim
wir haben hier die fleisch butter ich
finde schon erklärt lampen sonst rein
vegetarisch haben wir vorne also einmal
die pilze die wir schon drauf gelegt
haben und das sind vegetarische
würstchen und noch grillkäse und
inwieweit in die würstchen ja so weit
dass man sie zumindest schon mal
vielleicht einmal drehen kann damit ins
hirn die bläschen nicht anbrennen
ja also ich hab das jetzt hier nochmal
das geblendet aber so viel gibt auch
gerade dazu gar nichts zu erzählen muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen du die leute
wissen auch wie man grillen als letztes
mal zugekauft haben wir euch ja gefragt
was er als nächstes machen sollen und
ganz viele von euch haben currywurst
geschrieben klaus mitmachen ist ganz
einfach
wo ist curry ketchup
zack fertig currywurst dieser maschine
waren also ist das tatsächlich so liebe
zuschauer dass man eine currywurst
kaufmann draußen mal so eine pommesbude
oder so eine im bestand da kauft man
eine currywurst und zu hause macht man
meistens currywurst nicht selber und ja
zu machen ist natürlich ganz einfach es
einfach ne wurst die wirtin seiner
imbissbude kein geschreddert oder
gewechselt wie nennt man das konnte so
eine maschine rein kommt die in scheiben
wieder raus kommt currysauce rein
verlieh sie bewusst die wichtigsten drei
worte zum grillen kohle anzünder
grillzange denke leicht solches kohle
wie sieht deine top3 grill vokabeln
kohle tofu würste und grillkäse hightech
grill mit thermometer sonst nur zwei
wörter die ich nie benutze ich auch
nicht nur wegen klaus bin und grillen
bier grillsauce grillfleisch steak ich
gucke mein essen einfach nur die ganze
zeit an
und wie sie currywurst du musst auch
wenn zu filmen weil das ist dein dein
lamm das habe ich für dich gekauft nur
für dich ja die mit sousa das war's mit
unserer heutigen episode i st -germain
grillen beim klares danke klaus es uns
angetan hast beim auch so spontan ich
hab dich doch
und wir wollen jetzt noch für euch
wissen vielleicht könnt ihr uns mal auf
deutsch beschreiben wie ihr eigentlich
zu hause geräten habt ihr auch eine
grill kultur oder traditionen das
irgendwie im sommer ständig grillt oder
ist sowieso bei euch immer heiß und will
den abend oder macht ihr das eigentlich
einfach gar nicht so also das würden wir
gerne von euch wissen beschreibt das mal
auf deutsch und dann ist das auch eine
ganz gute übung das grill vokabular das
für heute gezeigt haben
noch mal zur anwendung zu bringen danke
fürs zuschauen und wenn ihr uns weiter
unterstützen möchte tim freuen wir uns
wahnsinnig über eine spende bei paddy
könnt ihr da unten könnt ihr einmal
drauf klicken da gibt es auch auf der
heutigen sendung
klaus hat unsere einige anekdoten
erzählt neben der kamera und treibt hier
unten und nicht woche wir glauben wir
nicht glauben
ich glaube du hast recht ich glaube
extra auf wiedersehen